I think there are three statements where we can certainly say by now that they are true.
We know that every problem that is in P is also contained in NP.
This is why we drew the picture like this. So, that's obvious.
If every problem in NP is also contained in P
that would mean that we have a polynomial time algorithm for
vertex cover, independent set, and clique.
We do not know that to be true yet.
Of course, we also don't know it to be false, but it's not something we can make a statement about.
And since we can't make a statement about this here,
we can also not to say that P and NP are equivalent or basically the same.
Now, the fourth one is probably the most subjective one so of course
it seems like NP should contain more problems than P
simply for the reason that non-determinism is just so powerful that
we would not expect that every problem that can be solved in polynomial time using non-determinism
can also be solved in polynomial time on a deterministic RAM
if you just think about how much time our simulation took
and of course it might not be the best possible simulation
but I think it's highly unlikely.
We can't be sure, but that's why I wrote here it seems like NP should contain more problems
and not stated it as a fact so that I can make a check mark here.
Now, finally, vertex cover, independent set, and clique, if we knew that they were in P
we would have a polynomial time algorithm.
Can't really make that statement right now.
And finally, vertex cover, independent set, and clique, yes they are in NP.
We show that they can be solved in polynomial time
if we have the wonderful and magic if better function available.